- [Instructor] So we've
talked at some length
about the Ideal Gas
Law, where if we assume
that if a gas in a container is behaving
like an ideal gas, and
the key assumptions there
are that there's no forces
between the actual gas molecules
and that the volume of the
gas molecules is negligible,
especially when we think about it
relative to the container,
well in that case
we can assume we're dealing
with something that's
kind of ideal, and we could
apply the Ideal Gas Law,
that the pressure times the volume
is going to be equal
to the number of moles
times ideal gas law,
times ideal gas constant,
times temperature measured in Kelvin.
But we've also talked
about in other videos
is that well, real
gases don't behave that,
and especially as they approach
their condensation point,
real gases aren't always, you can't always
make these assumptions about them.
And so what we're going to
explore in this video is
how we might be able to
adapt the Ideal Gas Law.
So, it's a better
description of what happens
with real gases, and in particular,
we are going to explore
the Van der Waals equation,
named for Van der Waals, same guy
who came up with the idea
of Van der Waals forces,
one of those attractive
forces that make it hard
or make real gases start to defy
assumption number one a little bit,
and what Van der Waals
went about doing is,
saying well let me see if I can modify
this P part right over
here, and this V part,
so it better describes real gases.
And to understand the logic
of the Van der Waals equation,
which we're going to see in a second,
let's think about how we
might want to modify P,
and then we'll think about
how we'll want to modify V.
So let's give ourselves a container.
Let's put some gas
molecules in that container.
So I've got some gas molecules here.
And remember, pressure
is force per unit area,
and the pressure here is
gonna come from the collisions
between the gas, the collisions
from the gas molecules bouncing off
of the walls of the container.
Every time they do that, they're gonna
exert a little bit of force on that area.
And so, you know, that's why
the more temperature you have,
these things are gonna move around faster,
you're gonna have more
frequent collisions,
the more molecules you
have, you're gonna have
more things to bounce around,
and so those are things
that if you have more of you're
gonna increase the pressure,
especially if you're holding
your volume constant.
Now this is assuming an ideal gas,
but let's think about
how things would change
if we had a real gas, where you do have,
let's say attractive forces between them.
Let's say they're Van der Waals forces.
So if you have attractive forces between
the actual gas molecules,
we will also assume
that the molecules are
not attracted to the walls
of the container, which
isn't always the case.
Sometimes they're more attracted
to the walls of the container.
But let's assume that
they're not attracted
to the walls of the container.
Well, the molecules of the middle,
they're gonna be attracting,
we're gonna assume
that they're uniformly
distributed about the volume.
The ones in the middle,
they're gonna be pulled
in every direction, and so
there's not gonna be really
a significant net force,
but the ones near the side
of the container, so let's say
a molecule right over here,
well, that's gonna have
most of its fellow molecules
are going to, in this
case, be to its left,
and so those are the ones that
it's gonna be attracted to,
so in this, and there's not
gonna be too many or any
in this case, to the right of it,
and so it's going to have a net inward,
a net inward force.
Similarly this one up here
will have a net inward force.
This one right over here
would have a net inward force,
and the closer we get to the center,
it's gonna start diminishing a little bit,
but as you can see, because
of this attractive force,
these things are more
likely to maybe gravitate
a little bit more towards the center
than to ricochet off the side.
They still will ricochet off the side,
these things are buzzing
around, super chaotics,
you know, everywhere bouncing,
but if there's some
small, attractive force,
it might be a little bit more likely
to move towards the center than to
bounce off the walls of the container.
And so as we talked about
in a previous video,
it's reasonable that if you
hold everything constant,
that the real pressure, the pressure real
is going to be less
than the ideal pressure
because of, in this case,
this attractive force.
But, Van der Waals, said,
well can I quantify this difference.
Well, what if we say the real pressure,
we know it's gonna be less
than the ideal pressure
because of the attractive forces.
The real pressure is going to be
equal to the ideal pressure, minus,
and we try to figure out some expression
that helps us take into
account these net forces,
especially from things that
are closer to the boundaries.
Well, for every gas
it's gonna be different,
depending on how they
interact with each other,
so let's just put a
little constant in there
and say, alright, well for
any one of these molecules,
the net inward force is
gonna be proportional to just
how many molecules it
has in the container.
So, especially the density.
So it's going to be, and the density
is a number of moles
divided by the volume,
and that would be for any
one of these molecules,
but obviously we have many molecules
and the number of molecules
is also going to be related
to the density, so you'd want to multiply
times the density again.
So you could view this as, okay,
we're kind of taking it into consideration
any one molecule, but then
we have a bunch of molecules
that are all gonna have a
little bit of an inward force
to different degrees, and we have this
proportionality factor that
helps us take into consideration
the type of gas that we
might be dealing with.
And so, you have this notion
that the real pressure
could be equal to the
ideal pressure minus a
times n over V squared.
All, we can algebraically manipulate this,
add this to both sides of the equation,
and we could get that the real pressure
plus a
times n over
V squared
is equal to the ideal pressure.
Now, what's interesting about this is,
Van der Waals said, well
if I assume that this is ideal pressure,
and this is ideal volume, well
maybe I could just replace
the P sub i, the ideal pressure,
with this thing right over here.
And that's what he does,
so we're gonna slowly
reconstruct the Van der Waals equation.
So instead of that, he has
P sub the real pressure,
plus, and this looks like
this wacky stuff, hard to understand,
but hopefully this makes a
little bit of sense that look,
the real pressure is gonna be
less than the ideal pressure,
it's gonna be the ideal
pressure minus something,
or you can say that the ideal pressure
is gonna be the real
pressure plus something.
And that plus something
is related to the density
of the actual molecules, and
there's gonna some constant
that's given for that gas.
And, I've only seen positive ones here,
which imply an attractive force,
but, if you had a repulsive,
but I won't even get into that,
I've only seen positive a
values used for actual gases,
so they're really talking
about attractive forces there.
And then we're gonna do
something about the volume.
We're gonna do something about
the volume right over here.
So we're gonna have the
real, the volume sub real,
we're gonna add or subtract something,
and then this is going to be equal to nRT.
Now, let's think about
how we'd want to adjust
real volume relative to ideal volume.
So let me draw another
container really quickly.
So, in this container, I'm
gonna challenge assumption two
and we're gonna assume
that these molecules,
that their volume is not negligible.
And so in this case or situation,
holding everything else constant,
if you want the same
pressure, and everything else
is constant, your real
volume, in order to have
the same pressure, is
gonna have to be larger.
The real volume, V sub r,
needs to be greater than
the ideal volume.
Why does it have to be greater?
Well, in order to have, if you don't make
the volume greater, these
things are gonna bump
into each other a lot
more, 'cause they're each
taking up a lot more space
than you would've assumed,
than you would've assumed
under the negligible volume assumption.
And so if they're bumping
into each other a lot more
and ricocheting off of each a lot more,
if you held the volume constant,
you would have more pressure,
but if you want to hold
the pressure constant,
well you've got to make the volume bigger,
the real volume has to be
greater than the ideal volume.
And by how much?
Well, the real volume
could be equal to the ideal volume,
and you just need to make space
for the volume of the actual molecules.
So the ideal volume plus space
for the actual molecules.
And so, we could multiply some constant
times the number of
molecules measured in moles.
And this b would be related to,
essentially the size of the molecules.
You can even think of it as
kind of a bigness factor.
You can think of this a bit
as an attractive factor,
and this is a bigness factor.
And once again, algebraically
manipulating this,
you would get the real
volume minus the volume
of our actual molecules, is
equal to the ideal volume.
And we can go back and substitute that in.
This whole thing is the ideal volume,
so the ideal volume is
equal to the real volume
minus some proportionality constant,
times the number of
molecules measured in moles.
And this thing that I have just generated,
this is the Van der Waals equation.
And the reason why I
went through this little,
hopefully conceptual
experiment thinking through it,
is that, at first when you see,
it looks really, really daunting
until you realize that this first thing,
this first thing right over here,
that's just the ideal pressure,
and then the second thing
is the ideal volume,
and then we make adjustments
between the ideal and the real
based on, okay, maybe we have some forces
between the particles, and yeah,
we have to take into
account the actual volume
of the particles.
And once again, the
Van der Waals equation,
it is not perfect, but it's the one
that is typically given as a,
a next version to get
a little bit more real
than the Ideal Gas Law.
You can continue to modify this,
you can do computer models,
you can do all sorts of things
that get you even more exact,
but the Van der Waals
equation is a good start.